Speaker 1: Let's go.
Oh, you know who we haven't heard from for.
For a while?
Our friend Tamisha in New York City, Tamisha.
Welcome.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
How is everything?
Speaker 1: Everything's good.
Speaker 2: I'm calling because I wanted to
just quickly talk about the absurdity of the
gun talk.
Yeah.
From right where they say, oh, let's open
doors, locked doors and rooftops.
But that whole premise doesn't make any sense,
because it would mean you would have to arm
every public place.
You would have to lock every public place.
Right.
And it's not really realistic to have armed
guards everywhere all the time.
Wouldn't that be like a welfare state?
Speaker 1: Well, it wouldn't be it not a welfare
state.
Be more like a police state.
Speaker 2: Police state?
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's completely unrealistic.
And, you know, the thing about it is they
never want to just say, let's try dealing
with the guns like we've talked about all
this other stuff and we've said the issues,
mental illness, but then they won't fund mental
health and then they say the issue's doors,
but then there's an outdoor shooting and then
they say, well, the issue is fire escapes,
but then there's one at a movie theater, you
know, I mean, they want to just push around
the responsibility and never deal with the
guns.
And you're absolutely right.
It's like, well, I guess everybody should
wear body armor at a parade and everyone should
wear a helmet at the movies.
Like, how far is this going to go before we
say, hey, you know what, let's just try dealing
with the guns?
Speaker 2: And it's like most most commonsense
people are not trying to take away guns.
They're just trying to make it so crazy.
People don't get them.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I mean, it's like, listen, there's some people
who want to get rid of the Second Amendment.
I take a more fatalistic approach, which is
like, for now we have a Second Amendment,
let's work within it.
Let's require liability insurance.
Let's make ammunition really expensive.
Let's limit the guns that someone under 25
can have.
Let's have a waiting period.
Let's have a psych eval, let's have more extensive
training, all these different things.
Let's just really make it so that only the
cream of the crop, so to speak, can get the
guns.
Speaker 2: Well, that's where the common sense
part comes in.
But we're dealing with people without common
sense.
And that brings me to the next thing where,
yeah, I'm coming to a similar conclusion to
you where our electorate is just not very
bright.
Right?
It's like I talk to people and they talk about
gas prices, inflation, and they talk about
Democratic policy and oh, the left is so woke
and the left is to this too crazy and radical.
But then they very much ignore the radical
left that's on the right side.
Of course, there's so much craziness that
goes on on the right and so much authoritarian.
It's all ignored because like I've even heard
people that I know that I'm not Republicans.
I talk about how they like DeSantis, like
you were saying with yeah, with Reagan.
Like I'm like really?
And I don't like to play the race card, but
I like your person of color.
I really don't understand his he and or you
support the LGBTQ community.
I don't understand how you can support anything
he stands for.
Everything he stands for is against any of
that.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I mean, he has a zero rating on LGBT stuff.
I mean, listen, it's unfor it's really unfortunate
to Miesha, but we're in a world where most
people are incompetent and I know it's so
elitist and it's so condescending and it's
so pompous.
I mean, listen, at this point, I've worked
with a bunch of real estate agents.
They were mostly all terrible at their jobs
other than to at this point.
I've had, you know, over 20, however many
years of driving.
How many mechanics have they had?
They've mostly been terrible at their jobs.
And now I know a good mechanic I've had, you
know what it's like.
It's just it's so common that people are just
incompetent or only minimally competent.
And we're kind of trying to dance through
this.
And you know what?
So I could be incompetent, too.
I'm not even saying I'm exempt from this,
but it's a reality that we're dealing with
here.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I agree.
I wouldn't say that I know everything, but
I do try to be informed when I form opinions.
I don't just form opinions based on what somebody
tells me.
I try to, you know, do my research and form
an opinion based on facts.
But it's less like some people just listen
to propaganda on news outlets and they say,
well, that's that's the way things are because
they said it.
Yes.
I'm like, but there's just so much nuance.
Even with the vaccinations, I hear people
say, well, you could still get it.
I was like, There's so much nuance that there's
very a variance.
People didn't get it at first.
So it was allowed to spread.
Like there's so much nuance to it that it's
not as simple as, Oh, if you get if you get
the vaccine, you can still get it.
So that means the vaccine doesn't work.
That's just a simplified way to think of it.
Speaker 1: 100%.
100% to me showed the kids are okay.
Speaker 2: Yes, they both a school 90 high
honors, so I'm very proud of them.
Speaker 1: Ninety's good.
Speaker 2: 97.
Speaker 1: 97.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
All right.
Well, great to hear from you.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right.
There's Michelle from New York City.
Always great to hear from her.
Let's go next to.
You know, I kind of want to figure out what's
going on in Florida a little bit.
Let's go next to her here in Florida now.
Are
you in Florida or Florida?
Hello.
Corker.
Well, I guess we're not going to figure out.